the team that was at the heart of the
covet situation this week the baltimore
ravens
lamar jackson eligible to be activated
on sunday that math works out he tested
positive last thursday it's 10 days
and he's got to be negative he's got to
stay negative and he can come back and
play although
you know what i don't think here's the
thing i don't think
i don't think you have to test negative
per se it's more about symptoms and
passage of time because i don't think
you do test negative
once you've had it and it may take
longer than that
it gets complicated and i'm not going to
pretend to know the answer the bottom
line is
he's eligible to come back on sunday and
he's not a risk to
transmit the disease to anyone else and
that's important because
otherwise it would be trace mcsorley on
tuesday night for the baltimore ravens
against the dallas cowboys
because rg3 on is he on injured reserve
of the covet list
he's he's on injury reserve because he
suffered that hamstring injury on
wednesday
so they need lamar jackson or they're
really in trouble
yeah it's trace mcsorley and he is
preparing to be the starter he's
obviously going to have to practice in
his practicing as the team starter right
now with lamar jackson out
what will be interesting we remember my
cam newton came back and and played
after his covet case and
there seem to be some cloudiness there
with cam newton and
lamar jackson hasn't practiced in a
while has he thrown the ball in a while
we don't know that
and to just come back and throw him back
in there
i know dr allen seals the nfl's chief
medical officer
talked about that acclamation period
when players come back
off the covet list and there is going to
be really no acclimation period for
lamar jackson if he plays they're going
to have to throw him back in there if he
plays so that's going to be
something we're going to have to watch
and see if they actually start trace
mcsorley because lamar is not
physically ready to go even though he'll
be on the roster and likely on the
sideline
for that game but they'll have a big
decision to make with him with little
practice time
a huge game for the ravens who are now
six and five a year after they went 14-2
and they
need to start winning some games or they
won't even make it to the postseason
this year and that would be quite all
right with the steelers because
if they would come across the steelers
again in january at relatively full
strength i think the steelers would be
in major trouble against the baltimore
ravens
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports